Ja, mal gar nicht so einfach die notwendige Seriösität in die Stimme zu bekommen, um zu sagen, guten Morgen, Dinos.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Da sind wir wieder. Vierundzwanzigste Ausgabe von Logbuch Netzpolitik, mehr oder weniger pünktlich, was auch immer. Der Stichtag eigentlich ist, das wissen wir ja auch nicht so genau.
Ja wir haben gestern einfach beide verpennt. Ja.
Ja, ist auch gut, ne? Ja. Traf sich ganz gut. War ja auch Vatertag.
Ja, ich war froh, dass du auch nicht konntest. Das, dass ich nicht ähm das vergeigt habe. Wir haben doch kurz überlegt, ob ich dir da noch einen Vorwurf geben soll. Tim, ich habe da gestanden und geregnet oder so.
Ja
Deswegen eine Freitagaufgenommene Folge.
Genau. Die Vorwürfe können wir ja dann in andere Richtungen äh werfen. Ich habe so den Eindruck gehabt, die Woche hat da eine Menge äh Vorwürfe hervorgebracht. Nicht unbedingt, die wir jetzt aussprechen können, aber die anderen Leute, so äh Dritten ausgesprochen haben.
Ja, Logbuch Netzpolitik hatte ja berichtet, dass ähm.
Diese Kampagne wir sind die Urheber äh wo sich wo dann eben Leute unterzeichnet und sagten, hier muss jetzt irgendwie äh Urheberrecht und so,
und ähm daraufhin erschien,
Dot com ist irgendwie so eine Seite, wo man einfach Text Fragmente oder Texte gut,
Zur Verteilung bringen kann. Eigentlich mal, ich glaube sowas war eigentlich mal beliebt, damit man nicht in ihr C-Kanälen so lange Sachen reinschreibt, sondern einfach nur so einen kleinen Link mit seinem Code, der dann irgendwie,
wurstig ist, da reinschreiben kann, dann kommt jemand anders im ISC repariert den und man bombt irgendwie nicht den,
C-Kanal voll mit irgendwie seitenweise Code. Und das hat sich aber, weil es ja über Web zugreifbar ist und dadurch halt ganz gut über Tor äh und für auch für minderbemittelte Hacker äh leicht anonymisiert äh zugänglich ist.
Irgendwie so zu so einem ähm enormen ähm.
Das ist so ein Instant-League. So, das ist so. Du willst was liegen, packst du auf Pace bin und fertig, dann gibt's da eine URL und dann steht da Text und.
Und dort erschien eine Liste mit Adressen,
und zwar Adressen Jena Personen, die diese wir sind die Urheberkampagne initiiert äh getragen oder mitgezeichnet haben, also irgendwie der ähm,
Der Typ, der die Domain registriert hat, Matthias Landwehr, äh dann ähm Charlotte Rosch oder was auch immer und irgendwie irgendwie so Adressen.
Und ähm das konnte man sich natürlich kurz überlegen, also es sind ja Prominente, ne und äh dann stand irgendwie drei
stand irgendwie als Kommentar drunter also Dogs die Vokabel hatten wir glaube ich schon mal als es um,
unsere Freunde gingen von.
Wie schreibst du das? Und dann.
Oder die null X. Wenn du wenn du wenn du ganz krass bist, falls das mit D null X. Also ähm das das das entdecke das
covern einer, eines Pseudonyms eigentlich. Also jemanden, der wie hießen die denn? Jetzt fällt's mir nicht mehr ein, diese diese ähm Hackergruppe, die da hochgenommen wurden. Ich die lange Verschwörungstheorie ausgefaltet und so,
die die wurden ja quasi gedoxt. Also sie waren quasi Pseudonym und dann wurden sie ähm.
End äh also enttarnt. Und äh das macht also jetzt enormes mit diesen Urhebern, die sowieso irgendwie der ganzen Welt bekannt sind mit ihrem Namen und veröffentlichte also eine Adresse, mit der eine Liste, mit deren Adressen,
So, jetzt kann man sich natürlich sagen, okay, ähm was soll das?
Und vor allem, was ist da jetzt, was ist da jetzt Hackertum dran? Also was was ist das überhaupt, was haben die gemacht?
Haben die irgendwie einen, wo er haben die diese Adressen, ja? Stellt sich raus, sind alles öffentlich zugängliche Sachen. Da ist also irgendjemand hingegangen und hat angefangen, einfach mal äh Hues abfragen, bei der DNIC zu machen. Wem gehört denn zum Beispiel die Domain? Ähm,
was weiß ich, ein Telefonbuch zu gucken oder so, aber es waren quasi öffentliche Daten. Das heißt, äh nur die wurden in dieser Stelle einfach nur zusammengetragen, ja.
Ähm ist ja auch so, dass jetzt im Prinzip ist es ja schon allgemein bekannt, wo so bestimmte Personen wohnen. Ist jetzt nicht unbedingt so ein großes Geheimnis, ja. Ähm,
und dann haben sie diese Liste tauchte eben auf. Und man könnte also jetzt sagen und das war auch meine erste, mein erster Gedanke dazu, so meine Güte, wie lahm,
Ja, also ist ja nichts besonderes dabei, irgendwie äh bei einer Domain halt zu gucken, wer da wohnt. Äh wer wer die registriert hat und entsprechend sind diese Adressen im Zweifelsfall auch nicht wirklich die Privatadressen, sondern irgendwie da, wo halt die GmbH.
Also ich meine, es ist klar, dass das jetzt alles aus Ruhe ist Rekords kam.
Ähm ja, also gehe ich so von aus, auch wie die formuliert sind. Also es sind auch immer gleich aufgezeichnet. Es ist eine Homepage und ein Wikipedia, einen Tag und so. Also, es ist nicht irgendwie,
besonders schwer, das herauszufinden. Ich meine, die Leute haben ja auch meistens ein Impressum. Und gerade, wenn das kleinere Urheber sind, sind ja jetzt auch viele beide jetzt nicht irgendwie Charlotte Rosch heißen oder so. Die haben natürlich einfach ein Impressum auf ihrer Website. Müssen sie ja haben.
So, also da musst du noch nicht mal ein gucken, so wenn die sich halbwegs ans Gesetz halten, haben die einen Impressum. Also,
ja? Weil jetzt wirklich keine besonders keine keine krassen Geheimnisse herauszufinden, wo jemand wohnt. Kann man bei mir auch rausfinden, steht auf meiner Website. Ähm,
So, diese Liste wurde jetzt also veröffentlicht. Man könnte also sagen, okay, was für ein Kinderkram, ne, was für einen Quatsch. Man könnte aber natürlich auch sagen.
Wie dämlich kann man eigentlich sein, diesen Urhebern,
so ein Sahnetörtchen zu schenken, um die Kritiker wiederum, dieses dieses Aufrufes,
zu kritisieren, ja? Und dann kam also äh meldete sich sofort Ansgar Hefeling, uns ja noch bekannt mit seiner Kampfankündigung gegen die Netzgemeinde, ja, Netzgemeinde, ihr werdet den Kampf verlieren, äh schloss ich zusammen mit ähm,
stellvertretenden Fraktionsvorsitzenden Günther Krings und veröffentlichte dann irgendwie einen Texte. Solche Anprangerungen und Einschüchterungsversuche kannten wir bisher vor allem von total
deren Regimen.
Mit dieser mit dieser Maske, mit dieser Aktion hat die enorme Gruppe ihre politische Maske vom Gesicht gerissen und fordern, fordern, sehr geil.
Und.
Ähm äh fordern, die Netzgemeinde soll sich von der Normis distanzieren. Also das ist wirklich so.
Oh Gott.
Äh ähm da muss man sich jetzt von distanzieren. Also die Netzgemeinde ist ungefähr genauso klar definiert wie.
Du bist gar nicht.
Eine sollen sich jetzt davon distanzieren und und Pipapo, ne,
In der Tat hat das eigentlich so gut wie jeder gemacht und also jeder, der sich dazu geäußert hat, hat gesagt, das ist eine dämliche Aktion, ist aber muss es eben ins äh rechte Licht rücken, dass das jetzt alles andere als ein ähm,
als ein Verbrechen ist, eine Liste von Adressen zusammenzutragen, die öffentlich erhältlich ist, ja? Ähm,
Das ist natürlich sehr ungünstig, das zu verbinden mit einer Drohung, dass man das weitermacht. Und ähm natürlich irgendwie, dass ein Einschüchterungsversuch ist,
Ich meine, das ist einfach dieses, äh, ich weiß, wo du wohnst. Ja, äh, natürlich darf, ist es keine Bedrohung zu bekennen, sich dazu zu bekennen, dass man weiß, wo der andere wohnt. Aber es, es schwingt einen natürlich sehr klar mit, dass man irgendwie eventuell dann auch,
mal hinkommt. Auch das ist nicht verboten, aber also ähm ne, es ist einfach eine eine dumme Drohung, ja.
Ja, das ist vor allem auch so ein Neonazi-Style irgendwie so völlig scheiß.
Totaler Scheiß, ja. Aber muss sich halt überlegen, der hat wahrscheinlich einfach irgendeinen Teenager äh mal einen Nachmittag gegoogelt, ja.
Verlage, die Verlage und zwar irgendwie,
was war das? Und Blessing, DuMont, Goldmann, BTB, ja, davon.
Äh haben auch eine PM dann rausgegeben, ähm ein sogenanntes Internetkollektiv
versucht Schriftsteller, Fotografen, Künstler, Musiker und Wissenschaftler einzuschüchtern und durch Veröffentlichung privater Daten gezielt unter Druck zu setzen, das ist der vorläufige vorläufige Höhepunkt
von beispiellosen, kunstfeindlichen Beleidigungen und Beschimpfungen aus der Deckung des Internets.
Helge Malchow, Kiepenheuer und sagt
sei angesichts des Jargons der Unmenschlichkeit, der sich im Internet schwallartig über Autorenkünstler, Intellektuelle und Verwerter ergieße, zutiefst erschüttert und an dunkle Zeiten erinnert.
Oh
Stimmung gegen Künstler erzeugt, eine derartige Kulturfeindlichkeit habe er im Laufe seiner Karriere noch nicht erlebt.
So, also liebe liebe Teenager von. Da könnt ihr mal sehen, ähm was ihr mit einer unbedachten Aktion für einen Scheiß baut.
Also jeder, der sich das zwei Minuten anguckt, weiß, dass das totaler Quatsch ist. Und das wussten auch diese fünfzehn Verlage, die dann da eine Aktion draus gemacht haben.
Da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, aber selbst wenn sie es gewusst haben, hat es sie nicht davon abgehalten, das zu machen.
Sagen wir mal, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie in so einem Verlag wäre und ich hätte irgendwie jemanden mit der PR betraut, der aus dem Ding nicht irgendwie eine Bombe zündet, den hätte ich sofort entlassen.
Na klar. Na ja, absolut, absolut.
Und da ähm.
Es ist, es ist wirklich, also man.
Wenn meine Muskeln das vertragen würden in hätte ich einfach die ganze Woche nur mit Kopfschütteln verbracht so, ja, aber das, das, das, das äh ist einfach zu viel für den menschlichen Körper. So viel, so viel kann man gar nicht im Kopf.
Ja, ich habe einen großen Teil der Tischkante inzwischen durch.
Einen der besseren Kommentare zu dieser Gesamtsituation. Wobei, ach du hast ja hier auch noch Alba Freude, hast du auch noch notiert, ne? Das geht so in die Richtung.
Ja, das waren, das geht so in die Richtung. Das ging also, Alba hatte dann so einen, so einen Artikel geschrieben, so Urheberverletzten, selbst das Urheberrecht. Der hat sich also irgendwie dann mal die Seiten von diesen Leuten auch angeschaut, also.
Auch schon wieder so eine klassische Replik ist, ne, mittlerweile.
Fehl Impressum fehlt, entweder ganz oder enthält nicht alle Pflichtangaben, teilweise sind die E-Mail-Adresse nicht mehr gültig. Und ähm.
Mit diesen Volltexten und so.
Ja genau, ein, ein.
Veröffentlichen und so.
Genau, einen Menschen namens Thomas veröffentlicht irgendwie auf seiner Seite Volltexte von Rezensionen seiner Bücher. Ähm irgendwie von tatz, fatz Süddeutsche und Interviews, in denen er erwähnt wurde, beispielsweise,
Beispielsweise irgendwie eins mit Angela Merkel oder so. Ja, also der sammelt quasi aus den ganzen Medien und trägt das da zusammen.
Ja, ist aber ein sehr interessanter äh äh Punkt, weil da geht's halt auch um. Ähm,
es gab da noch einen Artikel auf Zeit online, den ich äh auch getwittert hatte, der gefiel mir einfach super, nicht nur vom Inhalt her, allein schon vom Titel, weil der irgendwie der Titel bringt, schon alles rüber,
Lassen Sie mich durch, ich bin Urheber. Ich habe mich weggeworfen.
Ja, das war, das war echt.
Bringt dann einfach auch diese ganze äh äh Bigoterie da auch wirklich ganz gut auf den Punkt. Vor allem dadurch, dass er irgendwie sagt, naja hier ihr beklagt euch die ganze Zeit über,
das böse Internet und das schnelle Kopieren von Informationen, seid aber irgendwie alle bei bei Facebook so, ja? Und ich zitiere mal kurz hier,
ich habe nicht nachgefragt, weil ich weiß, was ich als Antwort bekommen werde
Ja, aber man kann sich dem nicht verschließen. Facebook nutzen nun mal viele Menschen und dort können sie, können wir sie erreichen. Wir wissen, dass das alles nicht okay ist, aber was will man machen, so machen das doch alle so.
Im nächsten Absatz, wie wollen solch inkonsequente Autoren einem Schüler vermitteln, dass er dadurch herunterladen einer MP3
Datei Böses getan hat, wenn der antwortet, ja, aber ich wollte nur ganz schnell diesen Song haben. Ich weiß, dass es nicht ganz okay, aber was will man machen, so machen, ist doch alle, weißt du? Und das ist.
Das ist einfach, man kommt so nicht weiter. Ich meine, ich bin in gewisser Hinsicht froh, dass dass diese Debatte als solche überhaupt auf der Agenda steht. Das hatten wir ja letzte Woche auch schon äh äh betont, aber der Stil hat sich jetzt in den letzten sieben Tagen noch nicht nennenswert verbessert.
Nee. Also äh vielleicht an der Stelle noch,
es vielleicht so der leichte, der kleine Hinweis an an die enorme Leute. Äh ich hatte ja auch schon meine mein meine dollen fünf Minuten mit enorm ist, als sie damals bei den Weeken.
Beziehungsweise an jeden, der der Meinung ist, sich äh nennen zu müssen, ja. In irgendeinem Kontext, ja, also.
Irgendwelche Knallköpfe haben wir auf jeden Fall dann bei mir zu Hause angerufen und haben mich irgendwie bedroht. Und zwar, weil ich ähm,
Ja, ja, klar. Weil ich, die waren aber auch nicht ganz so schlau, also ich habe dann irgendwie auch rausgefunden, wer das war. Ähm na äh egal. Das sind ja alles jetzt ist auch egal. Ist ja nur killefit. Da ging's um diese ähm Massendedosserei von ähm
Visa und Mastercard als Reaktion auf die äh Bezahlsperre gegen Wiki Leaks
Und ähm da da gab's ja dann die große Debatte. Die wurde ja auch, sage ich mal, in den intellektuelleren Teilen der Bevölkerung geführt
Ob das jetzt eine Sitzblockade ist, ja und ähm legitime Meinungsäußerung und so weiter oder ob das ein Angriff in auf die Funktionalität und Integrität von Computersystem ist. Lange Diskussion braucht man hier gar nicht zu entfalten. Das Entscheidende ist.
Dass es weltweit als Hackerangriffe dargestellt wurde und damit man sich nicht ähm Sympathien geschaffen hat,
und das ist etwas, wonach eine Aktion grade eine politische Aktion in der in demokratischen Staaten sich äh richten sollte, ja, auf ihre Wirkung und diese,
Einfach, sage ich mal, so eine hohle Drohung. Ich weiß, wo du wohnst. Das ist kein elegantes äh politisches Handeln.
Und es gab beim äh Kongress des Chaos-Computerclub einen Vortrag, der mit dem Titel Politik Hacken, wo auch an die äh Hörer sehr klar appelliert wurde und äh auch an enormem ist
die Dinge mit mehr Humor und ein bisschen mehr Eleganz zu machen, also beispielsweise auch so eine Seite, wenn man dann die Facement macht, das kann man auch streckenweise sehr viel humorvoller machen, als das als das äh teilweise stattfindet. Den Vortrag kann ich da also äh
Aktivisten, denen noch so ein bisschen der Eindruck fehlt, so mal wirklich wieder die,
nach vorne zu bringen, ja? Weil da sind inzwischen keine Lives mehr so. Lalz äh haben die anderen, weil also Liles haben jetzt hier die äh Verlage, weil sie, weil sie irgendwie sich als äh in einer kulturfeindlichen Zeit vom Internet angegriffen.
Sich ins Fäuschen.
Es ist aber auch ganz witzig. Also die, diese Ironie
ähm natürlich dann auch jetzt wieder irgendwelche Leute laut wurden, so aus der aus der Anonymität des Internets wird geschossen, ne? Das heißt, dann haben wir, dann kommt bald wieder irgendwie so, es kann nicht sein, dass irgendwie jemand,
im Internet hier Leute anprangern kann, da müssen wir alle demnächst den so durch ein Kartenlesegerät ziehen, bevor wir ins Internet dürfen oder so, ne. Äh solche Forderungen sind ja dann auch immer wieder dabei
das also quasi so diese anonyme haben Personen öffentlichen Interesses,
entanonymisiert deswegen dürfen anonyme nicht mehr anonym sein. Also das ist auf so vielen Ebenen falsch, dass man es nicht so wirklich äh.
Wirklich äh also da geht halt einfach da tiltet man halt irgendwann.
Ja.
Also mal wirklich ein bisschen mehr wieder in Kampagne und Außenwirkungen denken. Äh würde wahrscheinlich dieser Urheberrechtssache äh.
Schaden, ja? Da wirklich mal sein äh Management irgendwie ein bisschen zu beachten. Aber.
Achten sie auf ihre Management. Ja.
Reputationsmanagement ähm,
Da gab's die kleine Meldung, also hat jetzt eigentlich mit Reputation gar nichts zu tun. Ähm aber irgendwie müssen wir.
Leitung, ja.
Ja, wir brauchen das ja irgendwie überleiten. Das BKA gab bekannt, es sei sich nicht in der Lage, den Bundestrojaner zu äh programmieren. Vor allem nicht unter den Vorgaben, die da jetzt irgendwie.
Gesetzlich bestehen
Und äh da wurde natürlich dann auch viel drüber gelacht, weil sie ja offensichtlich auch noch nicht mal vorher in der Lage waren, sich denen von einer Firma zu kaufen, die in der Lage ist, ein halbwegs vernünftiges Myware zu schreiben. Ähm
Da muss man aber auch mal irgendwie erklären, was das bedeutet, wenn ich also wirklich so einen Bundestrojaner bauen möchte, heißt, ich muss wirklich ähm.
Haben ne? Also ich muss einen richtig guten, richtig guten Trojaner schreiben und ähm ich brauche vor allem die Connections, um überhaupt solche zu bekommen, ja? Also die muss man sich ja ähm kaufen,
und ähm da braucht man also eine gewisse Szene Verankerung und äh muss also auf dem auf dem Markt der Blackheads einkaufen und ähm,
Das ist natürlich, das ist wahrscheinlich etwas, was das BKA tatsächlich nicht leisten kann. Und das machen dann Firmen wie Gamma,
die mit ihrer Software Finn Fischer, das ist, glaube ich, so der größte äh staatlich eingesetzte Trojaner, den sie also in alle möglichen Länder verkaufen, auch nach Deutschland inzwischen. Ähm.
Wo
sich jemand quasi eine eine Firma darauf spezialisiert hat, diese Explods von Leuten eben zu kaufen ähm und da irgendwie eine Software draus zu basteln, die irgendwie sich ordentlich dafür eignet, ähm ja.
Die Bürger angreifen, ne.
Es ist wirklich so absurd, dass dass der Staat irgendwie mit dem BKA und dem BSI zwei Organisationen unterhält, deren Ziele zumindest mit bestimmten Themenfeldern diametral entgegensteht,
also auf der einen Seite versucht das BSI die Rechner äh der Leute möglichst sicher zu halten, damit ihnen irgendwie nichts Böses passiert und keine Wirtschaftsspionage
passiert oder was nicht noch alles, ja? Und zwei Räume weiter äh sitzt dann irgendjemand, der sich diebisch freut, dass äh das BSI für irgendwas noch nicht gewarnt hat, dass man das jetzt noch benutzen kann, um irgendwie dieselben Organisationen auszuhören. Also es ist,
abzuhören. Das ist wirklich absurd und ähm das kann eigentlich gar nicht angehen, ne? Zumal es auch für mich hoch fragwürdig ist, ob man überhaupt
dem Staat erlauben darf. Also ich meine, wie schätzt du diese Blackhead-Szene ein? Ich meine, im Prinzip.
Ist das der.
Ist das ja kriminelles Handeln. Oder.
Zu verkaufen.
Na ja, kann man das so sagen? Also.
Also Explods haben Werte. So, das, also, ich, ich, ich will
ich will's auch jetzt hier, was ich persönlich zum vom Bundestrainer halte, ich wollte jetzt nur mal so sagen, warum warum scheiterst das BKA daran, ne? Also das ja, jetzt habe ich ja, glaube ich, klar gemacht. Wenn ich, wenn du einen Explode hast für für ein bestimmtes, für eine bestimmte Plattform, bestimmte ähm,
sagen wir mal äh so ein iOS Explode oder was so. Wenn er es wenn er sich wirklich zu Drive bei äh eignet, ja? Ähm das kannst du für sehr, sehr viel Geld verkaufen.
Größenordnung.
Hm ich würde schätzen, je nachdem an wen und wie wie mächtig dein Explode ist, wahrscheinlich irgendwas zwischen sechzigtausend und einer viertel Million.
So, das sind so die die groben Zahlen, die man so liest. Es gab ich glaube, Andre Meister hatte auf Netzpolitik org einen äh längeren Artikel dazu vor kurzer Zeit. Den suche ich noch mal raus, wo es also,
um diesen Markt ging. Hm.
Den Markt gibt es ja. Und du kannst ähm enorm schön damit Geld verdienen als Fackel.
Ja. Muss man einen Ton ausschalten, sonst sind wieder alles.
Aber meiner, meiner ist raus. Meiner ist aus, ich habe geguckt. Ich glaube, das sind deine E-Mails, die da gerade ankommen. Oder?
Sicher? Das kann auch sein. Entschuldigung.
Also gibt es gibt auf jeden Fall diesen Export-Markt und da sind,
nicht unbedingt wirklich jetzt starten so aktiv, also wahrscheinlich auch staatliche Geheimdienste, aber es gibt eben auch eine privatwirtschaftliche Firmen und da ist eben Finn Fischer äh,
ganz klar zu benennen, die Software von von Gamma, die also wirklich sagt, hier ähm.
Oder sonst was oder das machen wir.
Und die sind da stolz und zufrieden drauf. Und die gehen regelmäßig shoppen,
in der Explod-Szene, um das Ding irgendwie zu pflegen. Und das ist natürlich auch so, man könnte das eigentlich ähm.
Man könnte das ja fast ähm,
ökonomisch rechtfertigen, warum sollte jeder Staat seine eigene äh Überwachungssoftware haben, wenn man einfach das outsourcen kann,
einen Profianbieter, der halt dafür sorgt, dass das alles ähm,
Ja, die machen das so aus einer Hand, die haben irgendwie IT-influsion training Programm, äh ein taktisches Portfolio und dann diese Remote Monitoring Solutions und so. Die haben das einfach, die haben da den.
Zu meiner gewagten These, dass das ja also vielleicht war ich da jetzt etwas vorschnell in der Bewertung, aber äh diese,
Märkte, die sind schon, sagen wir mal, kritisch. Ja, weil wir wissen auch alle, wer da einkauft und wer das größte Interesse hat, das sind halt Leute, die Bot Netze betreiben wollen, et cetera PP oder
dunkle Ziele haben. Außerdem sind dann eben auch noch die Staaten unterwegs, wenn das für sie irgendwie brauchbar ist und ähm,
im Zweifelsfall,
zumindest in manchen Ländern dann auch äh ganz brauchbares Budget, um da äh konkurrieren zu können. Das heißt, da wird einfach ein Marktwert geschaffen, entweder durch die Nachfrage äh von,
Staaten, die gerne Überwachung betreiben werden wollen oder von Kriminellen, die gerne äh Leute ausnehmen wollen. So und diesen Markt zu bedienen,
daran teilzunehmen und damit diesen Markt als solchen auch so zu gestatten, halte ich zumindest für diskussions.
Ist absolut verwerflich. Ganz klar. Also es ist ein ich also es ist ganz klar absolut nicht in Ordnung das zu tun,
Bin ich also ist auch etwas, was ich nie machen würde und wo man sich selbstverständlich auch in eine Situation bringt, dass man in Deutschland in, sage ich mal, der, der.
Der vorherrschenden Hackerszene sich nicht mehr blicken äh zu lassen braucht, ja, wenn man irgendwie ernsthaft mal einen mächtigen Exploit ähm an Gamma zum Beispiel verkauft.
Ja gut, dabei ist es so ein bisschen wie mit dem Drogenhandel, ja, da die Nachfrage besteht so und solange die Nachfrage da ist, wird's das Angebot immer geben. Jetzt die Frage, kann man das irgendwie legalisieren? Ne, also kann man das Ganze auf auf
Beine stellen, wo man sagt, äh es gibt hier auch einen definierten ähm Weg. Ich meine, derzeit ist das nicht
in dem eigentlichen Sinne verboten, ne. Also das ist halt jetzt wirklich auch die Frage, weil du kannst sowas natürlich auch als Dienstleistung verkaufen, was es ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch ist. Und natürlich sagen diese Security-Resucher auch, na ja, ich investiere da viel Zeit und Arbeit und Energie und Wissen vor allem, ja? Und das ist eine eine hohe Kunst, sowas zu finden und,
im Prinzip ist ja das Aufdecken von Sicherheitslücken auch ein Heeresziel. Was kann ich aber dafür, wenn der Betriebssystemhersteller, der in dem Moment betroffen ist oder äh Anwendungsentwickler äh in dem Moment nicht bereit oder in der Lage ist, mir
meine Kosten zu decken. Ja.
Das ist, also das ist ja, das ist.
Argumentation.
Das ist auch ein großes Problem. Also du kennst diese äh ach ja, wie heißen die denn, dass ähm,
irgendwas mit oder so die das sind auch so Verkäufer,
und die gehen halt zum Beispiel diesen die sind echt, die sind richtig dreckig drauf, die gehen zu diesen ähm es gibt doch dann immer diese Browser Challenges, wo dann irgendwie Google sich hinstellt und sagt, hier ähm,
Sechzigtausend Dollar auf den Tisch des Hauses, wenn ihr irgendwie einen äh Codex Secution Explode in der aktuellen Chrome-Version findet.
Und äh also quasi wirklich, dass dass dann etwas wäre, was wo man durch den Besuch einer Webseite wirklich den Computer letztendlich komplett äh besitzen kann.
Mhm. Wollte zumindest in Teilen.
Sondern loben die irgendwie sechzigtausend Dollar aus und aber, wenn man die sechzigtausend Dollar kriegt, dann natürlich auch nur dann, wenn man äh dann dazu beiträgt, äh,
also zu verdeutlichen, wo der Back ist und dafür zu sorgen, dass das dass Google ihn dann fixen kann, ja? Oder beziehungsweise, dass das Deft-Team für Chrome. Und wuppen sind so Leute, die gehen dahin.
V UPN. Die gehen dahin, nehmen an dem Wettbewerb teil, zeigen, dass sie's können und,
Sagen aber dann nicht, wo die Lücke ist und verzichten auf die Sechzigtausend und nehmen quasi die Aufmerksamkeit dieser dieser Wettbewerbe
Dieser Wettbewerbe, dass dann auf dem Explode-Markt klar ist, ey, bei wuppen, wenn wir irgendwie demnächst mal einen Drive bei Explor äh zum Verteilen unserer äh unserer Software brauchen, äh unserer. Äh dann können wir uns bei melden. Die haben dann einen schönen Explode für Chrome.
So und so sind die drauf. Und die sagen, was sollen wir mit diesen sechzigtausend? Ähm wir möchten ganz gerne lieber die viertel Millionen haben. Und hier in dem Artikel von Andre, da ja, guck mal hier, iOS ähm,
hunderttausend, ja, bis eine Viertelmillion geht das hoch, Eiweiß Exportser, Microsoft Word, fünfzigtausend bis hunderttausend Dollar,
Da kriegst du richtig Kohle für.
Firefox oder Safari, sechzigtausend bis hundertfünfzigtausend. Chrome oder Internetcom oder Internetsperre achtzigtausend bis zweihunderttausend Dollar.
Ja, da ist schon ganz schön was zu holen, ne? Na ja gut, also wir waren ja eigentlich beim BKA,
und ähm dem problematischen Bereich, äh ja, wenn man jetzt,
auf Basis von Sicherheitslückenüberwachung organisieren will, dass man da immer wieder Nachschub braucht, ja, was eigentlich heißt, die müssten irgendwie Unmengen an Geld ausgeben und bezweifeln, dass sie das überhaupt sich so leisten,
können dürfen.
Du willst ja auch nicht, dass dein genau, also Legitimität.
Und Legalität auch.
Also das sind beides denke ich, Fragen, wo's ähm ziemlich klar ist, dass das sehr, sehr, sehr,
zu sehen ist und ein sehr enorm krassen Eingriff in die Privatsphäre darstellt, wenn ich den Computer überwache. Also wenn ich mir vorstellen will, dass das jemand bei mir äh machen würde, ähm würde ich, wenn ich also sehr, sehr.
Ja und vor allem, ich meine, jetzt gibt es ja dieses vor ein paar Jahren erkämpfte Grundrecht auf Integrität der äh eigenen Infrastruktur, dem widerspricht das ja eigentlich auch grundsätzlich.
Ja. Ähm das ist ja auch die die lange Debatte um den Staatstrianer äh gewesen. Haben wir die eigentlich hier bei uns so richtig behandelt? Nicht so wirklich, ne?
Es ist noch ein bisschen vor unserer Zeit äh gewesen, eigentlich greifen wir das das erste Mal wirklich ähm richtig auf. Also Trojaner hatten wir zwar hier und da mal, aber ich kann mich jetzt gerade nicht erinnern, dass wir da.
Also die.
Rückblick schon mal getan haben oder haben wir.
Das Problem war ja irgendwie so, dass sie sagen, okay, wenn wenn der Nutzer oder wenn das Überwachungssubjekt äh vernünftig Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt
Also sagen wir mal seine E-Mails vernünftig mit ähm GPG äh verschlüsselt und sich einfach mal ähm Security-technisch,
korrekt verhält, dann habe ich ja durch keine,
denkbare Maßnahme, Zugriff auf diese Kommunikation,
Es sei denn, ich schaue mir diese Kommunikation an der Quelle an. Und deswegen kam ja auch dieser Name Quellen-TKÜ zustande. Das heißt, ich muss also ähm,
Wenn ich den, wenn ich die die E-Mail-Verschlüsselung beispielsweise nicht knacken kann, dann muss ich einen Trojaner auf dem Rechner haben, der Screenshots macht in dem Moment, wo die Person die E-Mail anschaut.
Ähm oder äh irgendwie den den Entschlüssigungsprozess irgendwie so
behindert, dass äh dass ich dass ich irgendwie an diese Daten komme. Ähnlich ist es bei Skype, äh Skype sind also auch äh verschlüsselte Verbindungen, die auch noch laufen, die ähm so ist das Verständnis nicht ernst nicht so besonders gut abgehört werden können, ja? Ähm.
Da. Auch da gab es dann eben diesen Staatstrojaner, der gezielt darauf, also ein Audiodevice aufmachte, um eben Skype-Verbindungen mitzuhören. Auch da wieder an der Quelle,
ähm die Kritik an diesem äh Staatstrojaner war dann eben, dass er sehr viel,
oder theoretisch die Möglichkeit hatte, sehr viel mehr als das zu machen, ja. Also diese Screenshot-Anfertigungen, die gingen natürlich die ganze Zeit und da konnte man natürlich dann auch äh private äh Informationen mit abgreifen
und ähm er hatte, das wurde damals vom CCC kritisiert, diese eine Nachladefunktion. Das heißt, man konnte ähm.
Im Prinzip beliebigen Code auf diesen Rechner ziehen äh äh oder schieben und dort ausführen lassen. Es ist im Prinzip, denke ich mal, bei einer Myware,
in erster Linie eine i ein Ansatz
um sie upzudaten, ja? Also ich möchte äh möglichst äh wenn meine Malwahl sich weiterentwickelt hat. Ähm ich
sagen wir mal, entweder neuere Funktionen drin habe oder ähm sie insofern verändere, dass sie nicht mehr detektiert wird von äh bestimmten Programmen, die sie vielleicht irgendwann mal enttarnt haben. Ich möchte meine Myware updaten können, als jemand, der ähm Myware irgendwo deployd.
Und diese Funktion ähm ermöglicht es natürlich auch ähm beispielsweise ähm.
Beweise auf diesem Rechner zu pflanzen. Also ich könnte ja, ob ich da jetzt hinschicke, okay, update mal deine oder ähm Speicher mal in Ordner so und so, belastendes Dokument A,
ähm ist technisch nicht zu trennen,
was äh den CCC dann eben dazu bewogen hat zu sagen, diese Maßnahme ähm kann eigentlich nicht vor Gericht ähm,
aufrechterhalten werden, weil sie eben zu einer, eine Manipulation nicht ausschließt, sondern ganz klar ermöglicht. Das war so Kurzzusammenfassung, die Diskussion um den ähm Staatstrojaner.
Ähm noch dazu war ja irgendwie ganz besonders schlecht äh geschrieben und so weiter gab's äh große, große Häme über den über die Qualität des Discodes oder so. Das jetzt irgendwie kurzzusammenfassung, äh Staatstrojaner und äh.
Im Moment ist sind eben die Bemühungen da irgendwie einen weiteren,
finden, der sich an bestimmte Vorgaben, die es da auch schon vom Bundesverfassungsgericht gibt, hält.
Ja, ich habe kurz nochmal nachgeschlagen. Also wir hatten Staatstrujaner äh,
In der vierzehnten Ausgabe, kurz als Thema, als um diesen Leak des entsprechenden Datenschutzberichts ging.
Ja, aber ich denke, jetzt haben wir zu diesem Thema auch genug gesagt. Äh macht alles nicht so den Eindruck, als ob das BKA da nennenswerte Fortschritte erzielt mit diesem Projekt.
Ich bin mir relativ sicher, dass sie einfach Finn Fischer nehmen werden, fertig. Und dann ähm hast du es auf jeden Fall mit Profis zu tun.
Okay. Aber das Problem bleibt.
Das äh rechtliche Problem,
der Legitimität, Legalität und so weiter, das bleibt auf jeden Fall bestehen und ich glaube, da haben wir ja auch durchblicken lassen, wieder unsere Einschätzung zu ist. Nicht, dass ich jetzt hier nachher als der äh Exploit-Handelslegitimierer irgendwie in die Geschichte eingehen. Also da bin ich sehr großer Gegner von.
Gut. Was haben wir noch? Google.
Google, ja, interessante, also interessante äh Wendungen eher philosophischer Natur. Ähm,
Was, also wie ist damit umzugehen, wenn jetzt so eine Suchmaschine, wie Google, sagen wir mal, die Suchergebnisse manipuliert,
können, also beispielsweise ich, wenn ich jetzt bei Google, ich kann es mal ausprobieren, ich gehe jetzt bei Google hin und gebe Mail ein, dann wird im Zweifelsfall mir Google Mail angeboten. Und ähm.
Man könnte jetzt natürlich unterstellen, dass Google mir deshalb Google Mail anbietet, weil das eben ihr Angebot ist und sie möchten, dass sich dieses nutze.
Also bei mir kommt tatsächlich Yahoo als erstes Ergebnis.
Was bist du denn für einer? Was hast du denn.
Ich? Na, was hat das mit mir zu tun? Google hat mir das gesagt.
Google sagt dir, äh Yahoo.
Und das erste ist ein. Das Zweite ist.
Du weißt ja, dass die weißt, du weißt ja, dass die individualisiert werden, ne? Bei mir.
Ja ja also du führst das jetzt auf mich zurück.
Ich würde sagen, die denken sich der Tim, wenn der schicken wir zu jahu.
Das mag der bestimmt.
Das macht ja bestimmt, das ist bunt.
Tja, na ja, weiß nicht. Wenn ich ausgeloggt bin, kriege ich immer noch äh.
Das gibt's ja nicht. Ich bin.
Herr Geier, ob man sich da überhaupt auslogen kann oder ob man das nur nicht angezeigt bekommt.
Problem äh oder Frage ist klar.
Aber darum geht's ja jetzt erstmal nicht. Also es sind verschiedene Mailanbieter hier durchaus vertreten, aber wir wissen alle, dass insbesondere diese Google Plus Integration schon,
extrem gewichteten Suchergebnissen geführt haben, die von Google natürlich dann vor allem als Erleichterung,
et cetera gepriesen wurden.
So und jetzt haben wir also die die Frage
also eigentlich 'ne kartellrechtliche Frage so ein bisschen darf Google das ja? Oder oder was ist überhaupt 'ne Suchmaschine?
So, weil ich denke mal, man muss einfach ganz klar sagen, Google ist irgendwie eine private Firma, die da,
einen Dienst anbietet, der sich Suchmaschine nennt und der sagt, ich finde für dich die Daten. So, wenn die sagen, okay, ähm wir bieten natürlich unsere Dienste da bevorzugt an.
Dann äh sehe ich da wenig Handhabe, die man dagegen hat,
und so veröffentlichte Google jetzt eine Studie mit dem Ergebnis, ähm.
Dass sie sagen, diese Manipulation von Suchmaschinenergebnissen oder der gezielte die gezielte Veränderung dieser Suchmaschinenergebnisse äh sei von dem ersten Inment von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckt.
Sie berufen sich auf die auf die Meinungsfreiheit bei der, bei dem, was sie dir als Suchergebnis liefern. Und ich sehe da ehrlich gesagt.
Wessen Meinung ist jetzt an der Stelle frei? Ihre Meinung, was haben Sie, was haben Sie denn für eine Meinung zu meinem So.
Dass das Google Mail für dich das das Passende ist. Aber die Frage ist, was ist es denn sonst? Was was bietet Google dir denn an? Also das ähm.
Wer hat denn da jetzt eine Meinungsfreiheit? Die Firma, der Computer?
Nee, hat die Firma. Also so verstehe ich das jetzt.
Gibt's jetzt Meinungsfreiheit auch für Firmen oder war das nicht irgendwie für Menschen?
Haben Firmen keine Meinungsfreiheit?
Interessante Frage, aber.
Eine juristische Person, ich meine in Amerika haben juristische Personen auch Eigentum, von daher könnte man sagen, dass ich mittlerweile sämtliche Menschenrechte auch auf Firmen erstrecken,
weiß ich nicht wie weit man das so treiben kann. Finde ich allerdings ein interessantes.
Phänomene, natürlich könnte man jetzt argumentieren, dass man auch als Organisation und damit äh Gruppe von Menschen äh äh die Menschen, Rechte für sich in Anspruch nehmen kann, aber ich habe keine Ahnung, was äh jetzt ein Jurist,
wie sehr ein Jurist die Hände zusammenschlagen würde über seinem Kopf oder vor seinem Bauch.
Also in Deutschland ähm wie es in Deutschland wäre, gibt's einen Artikel auf Telemedicus. Ähm.
Lass uns mal, lass uns vielleicht mal irgendwie davon weggehen, ob diese Firma ist oder nicht, die Frage ist, ähm die haben natürlich irgendwie einen Algorithmus, der der irgendwie nach ihrem,
Dafür halten die Relevanz bestimmt. Und an einigen Stellen manipulieren sie den von mir aus, ja? Äh oder auch nicht. Ich meine, sie manipulieren ja zum Beispiel die die nehmen ja auch viele Seiten nicht auf, ja. Könnte man.
Was heißt manipulieren? Ihr Algorithmus drückt ja ohnehin eine Präferenz.
Genau, also die können, also ich denke, dass das ja eigentlich auch nicht manipul, man kann nicht von Manipulation sprechen.
Es gibt ja nicht die Wahrheit, sondern es gibt halt ihre Interpretation der Realität und die war schon immer irgendwie so, wie ihr Code sagt, wie es ist.
Genau und wenn nicht woanders bessere Suchergebnisse bekomme, dann gehe ich zu einer anderen Suchmaschine. Kriege ich aber im Moment nicht.
Also irgendwas machen sie ja richtig. Also diese Frage der Manipulation ähm ist halt wirklich ganz,
'ne ganz ganz schwer da zu greifen und ich denke nicht dass man irgendeine rechtliche Handhaber hat Google irgendwie zu etwas zu verdammen wie ihr dürft eure Suchergebnisse nicht manipulieren.
Also weil weil aber die Frage ist, wirklich, was ist, was ist das das Versprechen einer Suchmaschine, was ist die Dienstleistung, die die anbieten? Und ähm.
Früher gab's ja so das war, glaube ich, ja, die das so betrieben haben, diese Web-Verzeichnisse, ne? Die haben ja nicht so richtig eine Suchmaschine betrieben, die haben weniger gecrollt, sondern echt gehofft, dass Nutzer da
in Verzeichnissen oder auch eigene Angestellte, in Verzeichnissen des Internet kategorisieren oder so, ne. Das heißt, auch da war nicht, war in keiner Form irgendwie die Rede, dass es da irgendeinen neutralen Algorithmus gibt, den diese ähm
den diese Firma dazu Nutzung bereitstellt. Fand ich auf jeden Fall eine eine ganz interessante äh Diskussion, gibt's mal ein paar ähm.
Paar Links dazu und ähm,
Also man, es, es zeigt sich natürlich in dieser Forderung, dass die nicht manipulieren dürfen, zeigt sich natürlich die Ohnmacht gegenüber einer, einem Privatanbieter, der letztendlich 'n sehr großen Einfluss auf die komplette,
Informationsinterpretation und Zusammenstellung der Menschheit hat, weil einfach, weiß ich nicht, neunzig Prozent der Menschen halt Google nutzen,
wenn Google dann entscheidet, was weiß ich, Thema äh oder äh das ist Treffer Nummer elf zu dem Thema, dann nehmt den halt keiner mehr wahr,
Treffer Nummer eins alle wahrnehmen, ne? Und das äh also das ist ein sehr spannendes, äh sehr spannende Thematik, die ich da sehe.
Aber ich denke, dass man da nichts dagegen machen kann, äh weil's halt ein privater Anbieter ja eine Webseite und du hast null Anspruch darauf, dass da überhaupt irgendwas zurückkommt.
Wäre jetzt so meine meine Interpretation, was nicht unbedingt heißt, dass ich das gut finde, dass es so ist. Ich sehe schon das Thema interessiert dich nicht so.
Ja, ich habe da äh kann er jetzt gerade nicht so habe da gerade nicht so viele Neuronenverbindungen, äh wenn ich darüber nachdenke.
Also es ist ist eine ungelöstes ähm Problem und es ist wirklich die Frage, inwieweit äh.
Ist da überhaupt eine Neutralität geben kann in den Ergebnissen, ja? Und wie, ich meine, es ist ja auch nicht so, dass der Algorithmus ähm,
Publiziert wäre.
Na gut, dann werden sie sich verhüten. Ja klar.
Na ja eben, da werden sie sich verhüten, weil das ist ja ihr Betriebsgeheimnis, das ist ja der eigentliche Wert,
dessen, was sie tun und deswegen, wenn sie das eben äh nicht so weit aus posaunen, außer eben den grundlegenden, zu den grundlegenden verwendeten Patenten, Patchrank et cetera, äh äh was ja mittlerweile beileibe nicht mehr
Das einzige Element ist, sondern das ist eine eine Vielzahl von von Algorithmen,
Vorgehensweisen, die eben das ausmachen, was äh diesen Google Suchindex bestimmen und,
da das eben nicht offengelegt ist, gibt es in dem Sinne eigentlich auch überhaupt gar keine überprüfbare Wahrheit, ja, sozusagen, also man könnte ja auch sagen, es ist eigentlich egal, was ihr macht,
Aber ihr dokumentiert, wie ihr es macht, ja,
Also in irgendeiner Form nachvollziehbarer Art und Weise eures Algorithmusses und dann äh sagt ihr einfach nur.
Scheißegal, was wir rausgeben. Wir sagen euch zumindest, auf welcher Basis das passiert und zwar konkreter als bisher.
Ich weiß, denkt nicht, dass das eine irgendeine Chance hat, diese Initiative, das äh so durchzusetzen. Ich sage nur, erst dann könnte man eben wirklich sagen, oh hier böses Google, ihr tut nicht das, was ihr sagt.
Ja, weil derzeit sagen sie nur, wir haben da irgendeinen Algorithmus und das ist unsere Interpretation des Webs äh EDIT.
So und ob das nun Meinungsfreiheit ist oder so finde ich an der Stelle eigentlich auch vollkommen irrelevant.
Frage stellt sich eigentlich nicht. So äh in in den USA ist es halt immer sehr wichtig, da wird das halt sehr, sehr hochgehalten, dieses Argument, ne? Und äh also ist halt irgendwie so der heilige Gral und äh wer auf den schwört, ähm,
Ist halt einfach, dass du, da weiß jeder, das ist.
Sie ziehen diese Karte eigentlich nur, damit sie ihnen keiner auf die Finger klopft.
Interessant ist eben, sie geben damit, sie geben damit aber im Prinzip zu, dass sie manipulieren, ja? Sofern, also wie gesagt, dieses dieser Begriff Manipulation ist eigentlich schon.
Frei, also genau, weil dann dann das würde ja voraussetzen, dass es irgendeine Wahrheit in Suchergebnissen gibt und wenn's die gäbe, dann könnten ja alle diese Suchergebnisse liefern.
Ja, also dann dann bräuchte man ja nur auf Wahrheit Punkt com äh äh gehen und sich äh äh
die Wahrheit einfach runterladen und aufm Browser anzeigen, aber so einfach ist es nun mal nicht, ne. Die Wahrheit ist dann eben auch äh eher so eine Sache und tatsächlich ist es eben auch wirklich so eine Interpretationsfreiheit, ne.
Also bei noch ein kleines Beispiel fällt mir so anekdotisch zum Abschluss ein, das war doch irgendwie letztes letzte Woche dieses Thema, wenn man am iPhone vier Siri gefragt hat, was das ähm,
Bestes Smartphone der Welt ist? Dann hat Siri ähm die greifen sehr stark auf Wolfram Alpha zurück,
Suchmaschine der man Fragen stellen kann, die dann tatsächlich sich bemüht, Antworten zu finden. Und man man fragte also das iPhone Siri, sag mal, was ist denn das beste Smartphone der Welt? Und dann sagte Siri, das Nokia Loomi anneut hat.
Weil bei Wolfram Eifer halt irgendwie die Information gespeichert hatte, dass Nokia Lumia neunhundert ist, hat das beste Smartphone der Welt.
Und jetzt äh hat dann äh Apple irgendwie Siri manipuliert, dass Siri auf diese Frage jetzt antwortet so, die Frage stellst du doch nicht echt?
Suchmaschinenergebnismanipulation, ja?
Ja, das fand ich auf jeden Fall ganz äh fand ich geil.
Alpha meint, dass es Lunia das Beste sei, das äh kriege ich aber schon wieder ganz andere Ergebnisse. Ähm sehr interessant.
Ähm also,
Wahrscheinlich haben sie es bei Wolfram Eifer angerufen, hat gesagt, ey, ihr habt da irgendwie einen Fehler bei euch im Algorithmus, der sagt irgendwie, der gibt die falsche Antwort. Äh aber gab's auf jeden Fall irgendwie überall, äh war überall in den Medien.
Naja, das ist natürlich toll, ne? Ich meine, Wolfram Alpha ist äh hier eigentlich auch nochmal ein,
ein Thema für sich, ne? Derzeit ist hier äh auf Platz eins das HTC Trophy Mobile Phone Black bereisen, weil es ich weiß ja nicht.
Ja, die müssen da auch noch ein bisschen optimieren.
Schon lustig, ne? Wolfram Alpha, oh Mann, ja. Gut, äh wenn man das Thema beenden erstmal, was haben wir denn? Wir sind haben müssen nochmal nach Holland äh.
Wir müssen nochmal nach Holland zurück und zwar äh gab es dann auch einen Kommentar zu der letzten Sendung, dass ich ja gesagt habe, mit dem holländischen Netzneutralitätsgesetz, dass man sich dann solche Sperren wie Pirate Bay oder so eigentlich von der Backe putzen könnte. Diese Äußerungen meinerseits ähm kollidierte zeitlich sehr genau damit, dass äh es in Holland
wieder eine ein Gerichtsurteil gehabt, was die zehn größten Provider dazu zwingt, den Zugang zu Pirate zu verhindern.
Ähm jetzt ist es natürlich die Frage, erstens gibt's von diesem Netzneutralitätsgesetz nicht die ähm die endgültige Fassung.
Zweitens sind natürlich Dinge, die als illegal,
identifiziert sind, seien sie es jetzt oder nicht, äh aber das ist ja dann liegt ja dann im Auge der Gerichte. Äh grundsätzlich natürlich davon ausgeschlossen,
ähm blockiert zu werden. Ja, also ähm insofern wahrscheinlich eine
etwas sehr äh boldes Statement von meiner Seite, was ich so nicht halten kann. Es scheint also so zu sein, dass in Holland im Moment im äh wirklich eine Sperre von The Pirate Bay,
angeordnet wird von Gerichten und auch durchgesetzt wird.
Sondern zwanzig Domains, die irgendwie dann noch irgendwie oder irgendwie darauf irgendwie verlinken oder sonst was. Und die ISP ist kriegen äh sonst sehr empfindliche Strafen. Viertel Millionen Euro,
wenn sie's irgendwie nicht irgendwie innerhalb kürzester Zeit umsetzen und so weiter. Also da muss ich also eventuell so ein bisschen zurückrudern. Wir müssen jetzt mal schauen, was ist, wenn dieses Gesetz wirklich in seiner letzten Ausformulierung ist, ob es dann wirklich eine Handhaber gibt.
Als illegal bezeichnete oder als illegal identifizierte Seiten zugänglich machen zu müssen. Ich denke nicht, dass man dieses Netz neutralitätsgesetz in Holland ernsthaft am Ende so durchinterpretieren kann.
Aber dann gibt's noch äh noch ein paar neue äh spannende Sachen, wenn man so von Pirate Bay redet. Es hat sich eine Firma äh dem Markt vorgestellt, mit dem Namen Pirat Pay,
und die haben irgendwie ein bisschen Traffic Management für Klienten gemacht und haben offensichtlich,
eine Möglichkeit gefunden Schwärme,
zu zerstören, indem sie irgendwie die Kleins, die da drin sind, mit äh falschen Informationen fluten und das, was letztlich dazu führt, dass sie sich aus diesem, aus diesem tollen Schwarm äh disconnecten und nicht ähm.
Nicht äh zu Ende herunterladen. Und die bieten jetzt ihr wollen jetzt ihre Dienstleistungen auf dem Markt anbieten, dass man also äh für so einen Preis zwischen zwölftausend und fünfzigtausend Euro äh quasi eine Datei.
Ähm oder oder ein, ja, ein eine Datei, denke ich mal.
Also ein Hashtag, ein oder mehrere Datei.
Ja oder sagen wir mal den Film und alles, was auf dazu zu finden ist, also dass sie diese Torens äh gezielt angreifen.
Und äh quasi da den Download vermindern. Und jetzt bin ich ja oder verhindern. Äh sie haben von irgendeinem russischen Film behauptet, dass sie vierundvierzig
tausendachthundertfünfundvierzig Transfers erfolgreich äh gestoppt hätten. Ähm jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, ähm.
Transfers im Sinne von so viele Dateien oder Übertragungsversuche dieser Dateien.
Das ist nämlich der Punkt. Also wie, ob da jetzt nicht wahrscheinlich einfach von den vierundvierzigtausend äh jeder fünfmal versucht hat, äh nachdem es abgebrochen ist, einfach neu herunterzuladen
oder ähm wie viele auch vielleicht erfolgreich waren. Äh dazu machen sie also keine Angaben. Auf jeden Fall, die wollen dieses Produkt jetzt auf den Markt bringen. Ich denke.
Vierundvierzigtausend klingt irgendwie in Internetdimension. Ja. Wie nichts.
Na ja, äh wenn wenn du Urheber der alten Schule bist und gehst davon aus, dass diese vierundvierzigtausend stattdessen ins Kino gehen, äh dann sind die.
Klar, dass da irgendjemand jetzt glaubt, dass das eine relevante Zahl wäre, das kann ich mir durchaus äh vorstellen, nur.
Würdest du davon ausgehen, dass jeder Film mehr als vierundvierzigtausend Mal geschert wird im Internet?
Du meinst jetzt mehr als vierundvierzigtausend Instanzen separat angeboten werden, deren Download dann komplett verhindert wird oder dass äh fünfundvierzigtausend Zugriffe auf die eine dann.
Fünfundvierzigtausend Clients wollen irgendwie diesen Film haben.
Ja. Kommt jetzt echt mal auf einen Film an. Also es gibt Filme, die ist das keine nennenswerte Zahl. Und es gibt andere, ich meine, es ist ja auch so, das ist ja irgendwie das Absurde,
die Filme, die auf und überhaupt in Torwart Netzwerken, das zeigen ja diese Toren Freak Statistiken regelmäßig.
Das sind die absoluten Erfolgs.
Das sind genau die Dinger, die einfach Kohle machen. Und wenn das Filme sind, die keinen Schwanz interessieren, dann sind die auch nicht auf. Ich meine, das ist ja eh ein Mythos, dass man alles kriegt,
Probiere mal irgendeinen Film, der dreißig Jahre alt ist, der dir jetzt jemand äh empfohlen hat, irgendein Arthaus, trallala, wertvoller Film, was weiß ich hier, Louis Bünuel oder so.
Ruf mal auf, es nüscht,
nichts ist da, sondern es sind nur die Sachen, die grade alle jetzt sofort haben wollen. Die oder die äh nicht totzukriegen sind, Star Wars und so weiter, ja? Und auch Star Wars, ich habe auch nicht so den Eindruck, dass äh
George Luca ist jetzt schon irgendwie auf Hartz vier äh angekommen wäre. Ja, also es ist einfach.
Ziel noch nicht erreicht oder was.
Vollkommen absurde Argumentation an der Stelle, weil dieses ganze nur.
Widerspiegelt, was ohnehin Nachfrage da ist, nicht? Und in dem Moment, wo äh diese Nachfrage durch legale Angebote auch mal kompensiert wird, äh ändert sich das Verhalten auch gleich.
Also es gibt natürlich, das ist ja eine interessante eine interessante Korrelation. Wir haben einmal eine Korrelation irgendwie die Filme, die im Kino Erfolg haben, haben auch auf Erfolg,
Und es gibt noch eine zweite Korrelation und das ist die Leute, die mehr runterladen,
geben auch mehr Geld aus für Musik, Bücher oder was äh was ihr Herz begehrt.
Na, was Freaks sind, weil die sich die Inspiration holen daheim.
Genau, sind beides, sind beides Korrelationen. Ähm,
Man kann jetzt also einerseits sagen, siehste, so dass äh wir wir teilen mehr, wir geben euch aber auch mehr Geld, liebe Kulturindustrie,
Ähm die andere Interpretation ist, die also diese mit diesen Daten müssen sich ja auch, müssen sich ja auch die äh Urheberrechtslobbyisten auseinandersetzen. Die interpretieren die Information, sodass sie sagen,
ähm klar, jemand, der mehr Interesse an Kultur hat, der kauft mehr und der lädt auch mehr herunter. Ähm,
Aber sie sagen, der lebt nicht,
Kauft nicht deshalb mehr, weil er mehr herunterlädt. Ähm und bei der anderen Sache kann man also auch ein ganz klar sagen, dass es da eventuell also man könnte es so interpretieren, dass Pirate Bay als ähm,
Werbeplattformen, auch die Zuschauerzahlen im Kino pusht. Man könnte aber natürlich auch einfach sagen, okay, es gibt Leute, die gucken im Kinofilme und es gibt Leute, die gucken auf Pirate Bay Filme
und es gibt gute und schlechte Filme und diese beiden Phänomene stehen erstmal nicht ins,
in einem Kausalzusammenhang, das irgendwie, also man könnte genauso gut sagen, ja klar, im Kino hat der Film Erfolg und deswegen wird er auf Pirate Bave vier runtergeladen, also da da sind die Kausalitätsrichtungen bei diesen Korrelationen nicht geklärt und deswegen versucht sie jeder auf seine Weise,
Zu
Verschiedene Interpretationsweisen. Ich sehe eigentlich relativ wenig anders. Man das ist einfach das äh,
die bittere Distropubion erlaubt halt einfach den Zugriff auf Kulturgut, der einfach
global nachgefragt ist sofort. So, ich meine, wenn die dann erstmal alles in die Kinos bringen und dann sechs Monate warten, bis sie in eine DVD rausbringen, ja, diese
denn äh äh auf ewige Zeiten einen digitalen Download verunmöglichen, dann kann man sich einfach nicht wundern, ja. Ich glaube, dass gäbe es jetzt,
Was weiß ich, hier werden James Cameron irgendwie seinen nächsten dicken Film rausbringt, hier Titanic, et cetera,
Avatar, wenn der jetzt irgendwie nochmal irgendwie so ein Evergreen startet und schon wieder ein Thema gefunden hat, was irgendwie alle angucken wollen,
So und dieser Film würde weltweit von Tag null an,
digitaler Download ohne Kopierschutz irgendwie für fünf Dollar zum Verkauf stehen. Das wär.
Meiner Meinung nach, ja, Liebe dann natürlich noch zu beweisen so, aber das wäre,
Ja, mit irgendwie voller Qualität und nicht irgendwie tausendmal umkurdiert und äh äh die Tonspur fehlt und so weiter.
Der Schuhkarton.
Mit mit allen Übersetzungen, mit allen Untertiteln, mit irgendwie ist das Ding in null Komma nix of
Natürlich ist das Ding dann irgendwie da auch wahrscheinlich mit äh dreißigtausend Seedern am Start und wird irgendwie äh fünf Millionen mal runtergeladen. Aber es wird auch einfach eine unfassbare Zahl an Käufen geben,
wahrscheinlich alles übersteigt, was sie im Kinoumsatz jemals gesehen haben.
Apropos Kinoumsatz, das wären natürlich die Freunde, die sich dann äh sehr beschweren würden, wenn der James Cameron diese Entscheidung treffe und das sind natürlich die äh Kinobetreiber, ne. Die haben ja.
Sogar, das würde ich noch nicht mal als gesichert ansehen.
Sagen wir mal, gesichert ist nicht, dass sie zu Schaden kommen. Gesichert ist, dass sie sich auf jeden Fall beschweren würden.
Ihre beschweren, würden sie sich? Die Frage ist nur, ob sie Grund dazu haben, also auch das, weil das, das Ding ist, es gibt halt Leute, die gehen ja, die gehen ja nicht deshalb ins Kino, weil das der einzige Ort ist, wo man sich den angucken kann,
sondern sie gehen ja auch ins Kino, weil sie das cool finden, sowas in einem Kino zu erleben mit anderen Leuten, mit Popcorn und alles, was dazu gehört und Aufregung und ein hübsches Mädchen noch dabei und das ist ja auch eine, ja.
Echt, die gibt's da auch noch, oder was? Alles. Kino ist geil, Kino ist ein cooles Angebot und ähm ist auch ernsthaft nicht besonders.
Ja, ich meine, du hast halt auch keine dreißig Meter Leinwand mit irgendwie deutlichste Rundprologic-Schnickschnack, äh ja, Dolce Ron-Prologic-Kasse, aber nicht hier mit dem ganzen TRX-Klimpeln et cetera, also ein Kino kann immer mehr bieten.
Ich habe auch keine Popcorn.
Und das äh wenn man auch nochmal ein bisschen zurückschaut in die in die Kinovergangenheit,
Ähm es gab ja mal dieses große Kinosterben, als das Fernsehen anfing, Fernsehen, äh also im Fernsehen, Hollywood und andere äh äh Filmproduktionen zu zeigen.
Natürlich war da sofort der Finger dann auch so, ja, hier das Fernsehen,
Ähm ist jetzt daran Schuld, dass die Kinokultur untergeht, weil die Leute können sich das ja auch zu Hause anschauen. Das war in gewisser Hinsicht auch so, solange das Fernsehen nämlich noch diesen Hauch des Neuen hatte.
Das war ja ein Videorecorder kam auf und so und es war einfach diese unglaubliche Expansionsphase äh äh weltweit und besonders in Europa
alle gesagt haben, oh ja, ein Fernseher zu Hause, jetzt habe ich hier Farbfernsehen und so weiter,
natürlich im Kino immer noch eine ganz andere Nummer ist, das war zwar Film, uns alles nicht so digital und hübsch wie heute, aber im Vergleich zu dem, was du da in deinem Pahl Krissel, Oval, Bildschirm da irgendwie zu sehen bekamst, was da irgendwie von so einer schlecht magnetisierten äh äh Kassette raufgespielt wurde oder dann eben
im Fernsehen halt mit mit Störungen und Hausantenne übertragen wurde. Das hatte nur den Reiz des Neuen. Die Kinobetreiber.
Hatten dann diese Einbrüche und wie haben sie dann gekontert?
Ja? Sie haben irgendwie ihre Kinos äh äh mit mit Trennwänden halbiert und noch mal halbiert und nochmal halbiert so kleine Kinokapseln da gebaut, mit irgendwie dreißig,
haben die eigentliche Experience des Kinos komplett zerstört und das hat ihnen dann erstmal auch den Rest gegeben, während dann der,
Gründer der CinemaxX Geschichte,
Damals angefangen hat, all diese ganzen Kinos, die nicht mehr klar kamen, die vor allem die Programmkinos alle aufzukaufen,
oder als Programmkinos für Liebhaber aufzumachen mit ordentlichem Ambiente und irgendwie gemütlichen Kinositzen und einfach alles in Ordnung, schönes Programmheft. Damit hat er so einen Erfolg gehabt,
dass er dann angefangen hat, auch alle anderen Kinos zu kaufen und dann mit CinemaxX quasi die Multiplex-Kino
Idee in diesen USA zu dem Zeitpunkt schon gab, auch nach äh äh Deutschland zu tragen und damit einfach unglaublich erfolgreich zu werden. Und warum? Weil die Leute nach wie vor ein Bedürfnis hatten an Erlebniskino in guter Qualität, weil's einfach eine Frage der
Qualität ist Angebots ist.
Würdest du denn aber sagen, also es ist ja so, dass es äh was du gerade ja auch ansparst, dass es eine klare äh Regeln gibt, dass ein Kinofilm,
Erst im Kino läuft, eine gewisse Zeit, dann kommt irgendwann die DVD,
und dann irgendwann könnte der mal in der ARD oder im äh im äh RTL im Privatfernsehen mal im Fernsehen kommen. Das ist, glaube ich, eine Zeitraum von ich da gibt's klar definierte Fristen, aber ich glaube, das sind so
anderthalb, zwei Jahre dauert das. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwie wenn irgend so ein fetter Bondfilm kommt, äh dann dauert das anderthalb Jahre, bis der wieder plakatiert ist, kommt,
am Ostermontag auf SAT eins oder so,
Ähm würdest du sagen, dass auch eventuell das eine Rolle gespielt hat, nämlich genau diese Exklusivierung, Exklusivisierung, die dann da auch stattgefunden hat.
Eine Rolle bei was gespielt hat.
Bei der Rettung der Kinos. Gegenüber der, also der.
Nö, also ich glaube, das ist alles vollkommen irrelevant, wann, wo was wie gezeigt wird, weil die Leute schon unterscheiden können, ob äh
ob sie ins Kino gehen wollen und da dieses gemeinsame Erlebnis äh Ding auszuleben, ja? Oder ob sie lieber für ihrer Glotze in ihrem Heimkino sitzen. Ich meine,
Klar haben viele Leute dann vielleicht auch sowas und finden das dann toll. Aber das sind auch die Leute, die nicht gerne ins Kino gehen. Also wer sich in seinem Wohnzimmer mit seinem dreißig Zoll,
Fernseher eingemauert hat oder fünfzig Zoll oder keine Ahnung, Videoprojekte et cetera und das geil findet, so der ist nicht der Kinotyp,
Ja, aber es gibt auch einfach genug Leute, die
da ihre Ersparnisse unbedingt in so frickeliger Heimtechnik zu versenken und die ganze Zeit darüber irgendwie ihren Konsum da zu bedienen, deren Leben darauf nicht ausgestellt, sie aber eben gerne
dieses Erlebnis Kino machen. Ich kann ja jetzt nicht im Einzelnen sagen.
Man könnte, man könnte sagen, die werden diskriminiert.
Einfach ein anderes, es ist einfach etwas anderes, ja? Es ist einfach die Dienstleistung ist die Form der Darreichung und nicht die exklusive Zugänglichmachung des Contents als solchem. Und äh das ist, glaube ich, das, was,
das gebiert. Und wenn Leute das halt einfach kaufen wollen und da fünf Dollar ausgeben für,
Zehn, also der der Preis ist jetzt austauschbar. Ja, das würde wahrscheinlich auch mit höheren Beträgen wunderbar funktionieren, schon äh vor allem bei solchen Blockbustern,
Und ich glaube, dass sich das eben auch dann gegenseitig einfach äh äh beschleunigt, weil natürlich dann nach zwei Stunden klar ist, dass das jetzt der Film ist, den alle sehen wollen
dann würde es mich auch überhaupt nicht wundern, wenn noch mehr Leute dann das auch im Kino haben wollen.
Ja ja, also ja.
Also das, was ganz im Gegenteil nicht in Konkurrenz steht so, aber das ist eine Debatte, die wird jetzt auch schon seit äh Jahrzehnten geführt, aber ich kann dem einfach relativ wenig äh
gewinnen, ne? Ich meine iTunes hat es für Musik gezeigt und ich denke, das kann eigentlich auch äh in dem Bereich genauso funktionieren. Im Übrigen gilt das auch für Bücher.
Um kurz noch zu diesem Pirate zurückzukommen. Ich würde da einfach nur die Frage stellen ähm also ich denke, dass was auch immer für einen Angriff, die auf die Betonschwärme fahren, dass das relativ bald äh mitigiert wird
oder von jemand anderem kopiert wird, sodass man dieser Firma nicht das Geld gibt und die andere Frage ist, hat er im Moment eigentlich jemand Interesse daran,
wirklich zu verhindern, das wäre mal interessant, macht das jemand? Oder sagen die, nee, nee, ähm mit Abmahnung, das läuft schon ganz gut gerade das Business. Ähm.
Beziehungsweise eigentlich finden wir das auch ganz geil, dass es irgendwie da äh geteilt wird.
Wird so ein bisschen die Stunde der Wahrheit werden, äh wenn wenn diese Firma sich ernsthaft äh mit einem vernünftigen Produkt am Markt äh positioniert, wovon ich erstmal nicht ausgehe. Ja.
Was für ein scheiß Name. Ich meine, wer wird denn da bezahlt? Die Pi.
Microsoft hat hunderttausend Dollar in die Bude investiert. Was von Microsoft jetzt eigentlich nicht unbedingt der große Schulterschlag ist, wenn du hunderttausend kriegst von Microsoft. Aber immerhin harten sie über.
Ähm,
noch kurz traurige Nachricht oder ja äh Peter Sunde hat ein Gnadengesuch gestellt, was den was sein.
Hast du jetzt eigentlich auch schon in den nächsten Teil rein oder? Nee, ach so, ja, okay.
Fließender Übergang. Peter Peter Sunde hat ein Gnadengesuch gestellt gegen seine äh gegen seinen Haftantritt, der ist ja verurteilt zu acht Monaten äh und hat jetzt mit.
Peter Sunde, einer der Mitgründer von.
Und Gründer von Fledder. Wie erwähnten es? Äh,
Ist also jetzt rechtskräftig verurteilt zu acht Monaten Haft und hat jetzt äh gesagt, dass er aus gesundheitlichen Gründen und äh zum Wohle Flatters ganz gerne äh darum bitten möchte, dass,
er entweder äh eine Begnadigung bekommt oder äh zumindest dieser Haftantritt äh sich verschieben lässt.
Eher äh gesundheitlich in der Lage ist und Flatter ausreichend international positioniert ist, dass man nicht mehr seine Prominenz äh zum Erfolg dieses äh Geschäftes braucht und der Frederik Nay ebenfalls ähm,
Mitgründer von The Pipe Bay und auch zu einer ähnlichen Haftstrafe verurteilt, der hat jetzt äh wegen ähm Meinungsfreiheit an den,
EuGH appelliert.
Und quasi wehrt sich gegen seine Verurteilung am EuGH. Werden wir sehen, ob der EuGH sich dieser Sache annimmt. Wäre aber ganz spannend ähm weil,
Im Hinblick im Hinblick darauf, dass Google sich auch auf Meinungsfreiheit bei ihren Ergebnissen ähm,
beruft, wer wär's halt mal eine ganz spannende Frage, ob äh ob Pirat Bay jetzt von der Meinungsfreiheit äh
ist. Und dann gibt's ja noch den vier äh den Dritten, das war der, ah jetzt habe ich den Namen grade vergessen, äh der ist untergetaucht, der äh hat hätte, glaube ich, im Januar schon seine zwölf Monate antreten müssen
und äh den da weiß man aber nicht, wo der ist. Das heißt, der entzieht sich gerade auf äh physische Art und Weise. Äh,
diesem Urteil. Also Pirate Bay, Leute, ähm wehren sich immer noch gegen gegen ihre Verurteilung.
Beziehungsweise gegen die Vollstreckung. Hat der hat der Peter Sunne gesagt, was was sein gesundheitliches äh äh Problem an der Stelle ist.
Nicht weiter drauf eingegangen.
Also in den Berichten wurde nicht darauf eingegangen oder eher.
Nee, nee, er hat's also auch äh spezifisch nicht weiter darauf äh.
Irgendjemand muss das ja gesagt haben, was der Grund ist.
Das ist richtig, aber jetzt zumindest nicht öffentlich gemacht.
Okay, verstehe, okay, alles klar. Hm,
Na ja, also ich glaube nicht unbedingt, dass man damit rechnen kann, dass er darum herum kommt.
Ähm zumindest wüsste ich nichts, äh ja, ist allerdings wohl durchaus äh optimistisch, dass er das noch.
Verschoben bekommt, weil er auch irgendwie für die nächsten Wochen Reisen angekündigt hat et cetera, also ist mir so ein bisschen unklar, was da jetzt eigentlich ähm,
also wie stark jetzt da grade der Staat eigentlich nach ihm greift, ja und,
also ob sie überhaupt noch ausreisen lassen oder sonst irgendwas. Äh ich weiß auch nicht unbedingt, ob er so als jemand eingeschätzt wird, der jetzt unter großer ähm,
Gefahr steht, weil er ja eigentlich.
Sehr bekannt ist.
Naja, einerseits war er sehr bekannt ist und weil er eigentlich von seiner Freiheit jetzt nicht viel hätte, wenn er eben nicht genau das tun kann, was er sowieso macht. Und das sind halt viele öffentliche Auftritte, also,
aber ich habe keine Ahnung, wie das eingeschätzt wird und es wird,
interessant sein, äh wie das äh läuft. Am Ende acht Monate Knast ist keine.
Ähm das ist nichts, was man sich äh besonders wünschen könnte oder was man auch ihm besonders wünschen äh würde,
ich kann nur hoffen, dass er da die mentale Stärke äh äh besitzt, da einfach durchzumarschieren und äh am Ende da wie für eine wieder aus der Asche,
hervorzutreten, denn er ist einfach, ich weiß nicht, du hast den wahrscheinlich auch schon paar Mal persönlich,
gelernt, ist einfach ein ausgesprochen beeindruckender Mensch, der
ähm auch wenn man nicht vielleicht immer seine Argumentation jetzt so ohne Weiteres teilt, zumindest irgendwie klare Meinung auch äh hat zu diesem ganzen Geschehen, sehr visionär auf dieses Netz und die kulturelle Entwicklung dieses Planetens,
äh äh blickt und da einfach eine Menge ähm auch sagen wir mal auf so einer,
wie soll man denn das nennen? Also er ist er ist extrem viel auf so
Meetings, ja, wo man äh so als Normalsterblicher nicht so ohne Weiteres hinkommt. Er ist
extrem gut vernetzt und äh sehr hoch angesehen, was eben so diese ganze äh intellektuelle Debatte auf so einer Metaebene äh äh die so weltweit stattfindet, betrifft und ähm,
spielt da eben seine Rolle und ist da äh auch respektiert. Und ähm ich glaube, dass,
Das jetzt, dass dieser Haft, wenn sie den Eintritt äh äh bestenfalls eine Zäsur ist an an der Stelle.
Ja, aber es, also ich, ich,
Erstens, dass er das relativ gut wegstecken würde, wie du schon sagst, trotzdem äh würde ich das als ein sehr traurigen Tag interpretieren für mich selber zu wissen, dass er äh in Haft gehen muss.
Also das wär wäre für mich schon irgendwie so ein ähm,
sagen wir mal mit sehr, sehr trauriger ähm Moment, der das zu sehen, dass das ihm das.
Naja, na klar. Kein, keine Frage.
Womit wir beim letzten Thema für heute wären, hat noch mit Peter Sohne zu tun, nämlich Fletter. Ja, also wie gesagt, ich habe das ja schon mal gesagt, Peter Sohne hat uns nicht nur den Pirate gebracht, sondern auch den und ähm,
Jetzt gibt's bei Instacast dem ähm ersten.
Podcast der Flatter Integration hatte.
Die erste Software überhaupt, die Flatter-Integration hatte.
Was ein bisschen, glaube ich, äh auch auf deine dein freundliches äh auf deinen freundlichen Hinweis ein bisschen zurückging.
War da aktiv, ja.
Und ähm er hat dafür ja auch einen Preis bekommen, ne. Also irgendwie eine es war doch irgendwas ausgelobt von.
Hat er nicht den ersten Preis gemacht, aber weil er, ja gut, es gab da halt so diese Developer-Challenge et cetera äh,
Nicht nicht nicht weiter relevant. Auf jeden Fall hat das schon eine Menge bewegt. Also das das äh da Flatter integriert war. Das hat äh erstens gut funktioniert und funktioniert ja in gewisser Hinsicht auch immer noch. Ähm und ähm,
hat wohl auch gezeigt, dass das ähm ein Weg ist für Popularität doch enorm zuzunehmen.
Und leider sagte jetzt, als er ein Major-Update seiner äh Software rausgeben wollte in den Apple Store, sagte Apple dann, äh ja, ähm.
David heißt der, ne? Martin, lieber Martin, ähm guck doch mal bitte unsere Guidelines an,
steht doch drin, dass irgendwie keine Kohle verteilt wird äh außer über unsere Verdaffe vorgegebene Infrastruktur.
Also noch ein bisschen komplexer, also erstmal ähm für die Leute, die noch immer noch nicht verstanden haben, wie funktioniert
als kleiner also die Kernidee ist, man äh hat Geld auf dem Flatterkonto, das bewegt man da äh einmalig irgendwie hin und dann von diesem Kuchen
kummiert man ein monatlich ein festen,
aber wird die Zeit auch mal wieder anpassbaren Betrag äh ins Netz und wer dann davon einen Anteil bekommt, das bestimmt man durch diese Flatterklicks. Das heißt, die eigentliche Zahlungstransaktion findet halt innerhalb von,
wird er monatlich irgendwie ausgeklingelt und durch diese Flatterklicks bestimmt man einfach nur, wer noch an diesem Kuchen, den man da austeilt, wie groß auch immer sein mag, dran teilnimmt.
In dem Moment, wo eine Software Flatter integriert,
übernimmt quasi die Applikation, die Funktion dieses Flatterknopfes, wie man ihn auf Webseiten findet und,
Dot com weiß eben auch, dass das jetzt durch diese Applikation durchgegangen ist, et cetera und es hat den Vorteil, dass man sich nicht immer wieder anmelden muss und Web Cookies in dieser ganzen Climbin, sondern das geht eben so modern über O aus äh authentifizierung, wie man sie eben
loggen sie sich über Facebook ein et cetera und wittern natürlich vor allem schon ganz gut kennen durfte. Jetzt.
Ist diese äh Integration schon eine Weile drin und war wahrscheinlich bei Apple noch nie so richtig auf dem Radar, also in der Version eins fünf von, ist ja ist ja nicht nur eine Software, sondern ist ja genau genommen zwei. Es ist Insta-Cast und eine äh dieser sogenannte HD-Version für das iPad
die sich ein bisschen anders bedient und er hat dann jetzt eine Version zwei null, von beiden herausgebracht,
interessanterweise kam die iPhone-Version dann auch erstmal problemlos durch und bei der HD Version gab's dann eben diese Einwände.
Die Frage ist natürlich jetzt, wie bewertet Apple äh Dusp
Apples Guidelines sagen erstens, du darfst halt jetzt hier nix an uns vorbei verkaufen, in deiner App, also wenn's so eine Kauftransaktion gibt, dann
hat das eben gefälligst über unser Storesystem zu funktionieren und wir kriegen dann unseren Share von dreißig Prozent. Andererseits sagen sie auch,
wenn du Spenden für Charity Organisations ähm hast, dann muss das äh,
los sein, also dann darf.
Hast du daran nicht verdienen.
Genau, dann darfst du daran nicht äh äh verdienen.
Jetzt ist es so, dass eben bei Fletter es explizit auch noch eine Unterstützung gibt für Organisations, wo dann Flater auch auf ihren eigenen Anteil verzichtet,
Und ich bin mir nicht ganz so sicher, ob das nicht auch bedeutet, dass die Apps, die ja an jedem Flatter-Klick auch nochmal fünf Prozent,
also nicht auch nochmal, sondern vielleichter Teil die zehn Prozent, die sie normalerweise nehmen, dann mit dieser Applikation.
Ob in dem Fall, da ja die Transaktion kein,
Bonus für Flatter hat, ob der Bonus dann eben auch für die Ups wegfällt. Ich weiß es nicht genau, ich vermute es aber. Sodass an der Stelle wahrscheinlich auch so argumentiert werden könnte, dass das dann tatsächlich so ist.
Ähm inwieweit sie sich jetzt an dem Rest und dem eigentlichen Kernfunktion äh stören äh kann ich kann man schwer beurteilen,
Es ist ja nicht so, dass es keine anderen Anwendungen im iOS Store gäbe,
die auch so Ausschüttungsmodelle im Hintergrund haben, wie zum Beispiel, die ja auch so Geld einnehmen für Autoren et cetera und auch diese Software befinden sich ja im App Store.
Ich muss zugeben, dass trotz des ganzen was da in den letzten Wochen rund um Rede bildet, die sich abgefeiert hat
Ähm ich weiß nicht, ob du das mitbekommen hast, aber da gibt's dann eben weil die halt Geld nehmen, äh das quasi schon mal vorrätig halten und es dann weiterleiten, wenn
ein Autor sagt, ja jetzt benutze ich, jetzt will ich auch bei euch mitspielen und jetzt gibt mir mal das Geld, was ihr schon für mich eingenommen habt. Es gibt sowas ähnliches bei Flatter.
Das funktionierte aber grundsätzlich anders, nämlich
Wenn du jetzt jemanden flettern willst, der noch gar nicht an Flatter teilnimmt und du äh referenzierst ihn über etwas, wo später das bewiesen werden kann, was weiß ich, dein Twitter-Account, ja, ich könnte sagen, hier der
den äh will ich jetzt mal flettern und äh Flatter weiß aber gar nichts von dir
dann wird dieser Klick erstmal vorgemerkt. Das ist so ein sogenannter Pending-Click
und äh der hat keinerlei finanzieller Auswirkungen, das heißt, der wird auch nicht am Ende des Monats eingezogen.
Bis du dann eben wirklich mal kommst und sagst, hier ich bin derjenige, der jetzt hier durch so einen Twitter-O-Aus-Login beweisen kann, dass ich das jetzt auch wirklich bin mit diesem Account
erst dann bekommst du in dem Monat, wo du das durchführst, dass diesen Klick und sollte es halt eine Subscribchen sein oder so, dann entsprechend auch weitere.
Ab dem Moment ist dann diese Assoziation auch klar. Ähnliche Integration gibt es auch in andere äh Netze, also,
Facebook weiß ich jetzt nicht ganz genau, das scheint da aus irgendwelchen Gründen so noch nicht drin zu sein, aber wir haben ja jetzt auch äh in ihrer Api zum Beispiel vorgesehen, dass du, wenn du jetzt dein dein eigenes social Network hast,
Ja, sagen wir mal, du hast so was wie.
Ähm keine Ahnung, mir fällt immer nur als gutes Beispiel ein hier von Mekabod, diese Community Plattform, wo die Leute ihre drei D Designs sharen, wo sie ja optional, wenn die Leute einen Flatterklick haben, auch,
schon dann den Button anzeigen und wenn die dann künftig auch mit dieser neuen AP ähm losmarschieren, was die wohl auch vorhaben, soweit ich da informiert bin,
dann ähm könnten sie eben quasi auch schon ähm für User einen Flatterbutton anbieten, die noch gar keinen Flat-Account haben,
eben dann so mit Flatter verworben sind hintenrum, dass dann eben später der User sieht, ah, jetzt wollen mich dreißig Leute haben hier schon so einen Klick gegeben, ich bin da aber noch gar nicht auf der Plattform, mal habe nichts davon,
dann gehe ich da halt hin und sage ja, hier ist mein, jetzt habe ich mich hier hintenrum authentifiziert. Äh ab jetzt äh äh will ich mir das eben auch holen. Was auch eigentlich eine extrem,
coole Sache ist. Na ja, zurück zu Instacast, jetzt hängen halt diese Updates, das heißt, dieses HRD zwo null ist noch gar nicht rausgekommen. Bei dem,
bei der iPhone-Version, wo die zwei null ja schon durch war, hängt jetzt das Update auf die zwei null eins.
Das muss man jetzt mal abwarten. Also ich bin da noch nicht bereit, da groß zu verteufeln. Das wäre natürlich eine große Enttäuschung, wenn Apple ähm entscheidet, dass das mit ihren Store Guide Lines nicht zu vereinbaren ist.
So und dann muss ich jetzt wirklich mal sagen, da ähm natürlich, also auch da, wie eigentlich in der ganzen Sendung, äh
sage ich ja schon immer so, dass ich irgendwie wir müssen halt verstehen, worauf wir uns da einlassen und selbstverständlich, ne, wir haben diese iPhones halt gekauft und äh es ist klar, wenn wir sie nicht jäh breaken, dann äh bestimmt Apple, was da drauf zu funktionieren hat und was nicht. Ähm
und man kann auch deren
Rationale dahinter das Payment-Modelle nur über sie laufen dürfen, verstehen, weil ähm sonst würde ja jeder äh vielleicht seine App gratis über den App Store anbieten und
privat äh das Upgrade zum Pro oder so verkaufen, ja? Ähm aber eine also.
Die Tatsache, dass es im Raum schwebt, dass Apple eventuell dieses Flatter.
Von einer kompletten, von einer kompletten Gerätefamilie.
Von zwei Geräte von mir, ein Tablet und iPhones ähm rauszerrt. Ähm das ist schon eine ein sehr krasser Einschnitt,
ähm und das ist schon eine, denke ich, eine eine Richtlinie, die sie dann da für ihre Apps.
Was heißt rauszerrt? Also ihre Argumentation ist natürlich ob sie die überhaupt zulassen. So, ja nur weil da jetzt.
Ja genau, aber sie sagen, dass das verbieten wir. Es stünde im Raum.
Noch sagen sie das nicht.
Noch sagen sie's nicht, aber aber wenn sie also diese Macht, die sie da zeigen würden, wenn sie das täten, ähm wäre.
Hatten wir jetzt schon hunderttausend Mal diesen Fall. Das ist halt einfach äh we make the rolls, ne? Also das ist halt äh das ist halt einfach sie haben nie was anderes behauptet so. Ja, also man kann dir da zumindest keine Doppelzüngigkeit äh vorwerfen, ne.
Absolut nicht, aber meint, nee, absolut nicht, jedes Mal nicht. Sie haben das immer so behauptet, dann muss man sich auch irgendwie klar, das weiß, sollte man wissen, wenn man so ein Gerät kauft, dann sollte man wissen, wenn man dafür Software entwickelt. Schön ist das trotzdem nicht.
Schön ist das nicht.
Nö, das ist nicht toll. Ich meine, man müsste sich jetzt auch mal überlegen, was denn das eigentlich bedeuten würde. Ja, also angenommen äh Flatter wäre jetzt tatsächlich ein ähm
Dienst, der ihrer Meinung nach da einfach nichts zu suchen hat, beziehungsweise der, wenn er da äh sein will
eben auch ein Beteiligungsmodell für Apple äh vorsieht. Das würde wiederum bedeuten, dass halt dreißig Prozent der Umsätze
bei Apple hängen bleiben müssten, sprich dass von jedem der also das,
technisch sehr, sehr, sehr schwierig, ja, weil ja zu dem Zeitpunkt des Klicks und das ist, glaube ich, jetzt auch Teil der Argumentation von äh also,
kannst mal davon ausgehen, dass da jetzt grade im Hintergrund,
eine Menge diskutiert wird, ja? Teil der Argumentation wird sicherlich sein, dass er mit diesem Klick überhaupt gar keine finanzielle Transaktion stattfindet,
Ja, also das ist ja kein, ich kaufe mal was, sondern es ist eben,
eine eine extrem innovative Ansatz an Geldverteilung, ne? Äh der eben tatsächlich zum Zeitpunkt der Interaktion mit der App.
Nicht definiert, wie viel Geld da grade transferiert wird.
Also man kann diesen Anteil sozusagen zu diesem Zeitpunkt gar nicht bilden.
Theoretisch könnte man natürlich dann hintenrum sagen, ja, wenn Flatter aber jetzt hier mitzählt, wie viel ähm Klicks durch diese App auf eine iOS-Plattform stattgefunden haben, dann gehen dann eben nicht nur die üblichen zehn Prozent,
runter, sondern nochmal dreißig Prozent für Apple, was hanebüchen wäre, ja und was sicherlich auch dann nicht getragen werden würde von äh Flatter,
Geschweige denn von den Usern, ähm ja, wäre doch mal ein anderes Ding, aber das ist schwierig zu beurteilen, weil ich meine, was ist denn dann
mit wo die ab eben gewisser Hinsicht auch an diesem Ökosystem teilnimmt auch wenn's da wiederum andere Schritte sind, ne? Naja, also es ist sehr schwer zu beurteilen zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wie das ausgeht, äh.
Ich wäre.
Wir wir.
Überrascht, wenn Apple da hart bleibt, aber ich weiß es halt nicht, ne.
Zeigt wirklich mal so was, was eben,
in was für eine Welt wir uns begeben, wenn wir wirklich Rechner haben, die auf denen wir als Nutzer eingeschlossen sind. Ich weiß, dass du das da jetzt gerne wieder relativierst und wir haben's, man muss ja auch einfach sagen, wir haben uns ja alle darauf eingelassen, als wir diese Geräte gekauft haben. Aber ähm.
Die grundsätzliche Idee irgendwie so Geräte zu kaufen
deren Herrmann nicht ist ohne weiteres wo man nicht ein Administrator Zugang hat wo man noch nicht mal selber für Programmieren kann ohne irgendwie so ein Developer Account zu haben,
Ist erstmal eine relativ schlechte Idee.
Ja, also es hat viele Facetten, ne? Also das ist äh immer, immer, immer einfach da zu sagen, das ist jetzt irgendwie eine schlechte äh Idee und im nächsten Moment reden wir dann wieder über Security und es ist auf einmal wieder eine verdammt.
So, ne? Also das das ist halt einfach nicht so einfach zu bewerten und ähm was für mich eigentlich noch.
Die größere Frage dahinter ist es eben ganz konkret, wie sieht das eigentlich mit der Zukunft von Payment-Systemen an sich aus? Weil, ich meine, wenn irgendetwas Innovation braucht im Internet, dann ist es Payment.
Hängen wir einfach an Systemen dran, ja? Kreditkarten, Realitäten, Banken
Man sieht, wie Innovationsfreude von Banken, da braucht man sich nur seine Online-Banking äh äh Welt mal genauer anzuschauen, wenn's denn überhaupt eine gibt
das ist einfach mal der World Garden schlechthin, ja? Also Apple irgendwie ein Klacks dagegen, auch wenn man,
davon ausgehen kann, dass Apple irgendwann seine Geräte macht und seine äh Userzahlen und äh ich meine, man muss sich mal nur anschauen, wie viele Leute ein iTunes Account haben, wo,
buchbare Kreditkarteninformationen und ähnliches hinterlegt sind, wenn sie und davon gehe ich eigentlich aus, dass sie das irgendwann tun werden, wenn ich jetzt dieses Jahr in irgendeiner Zukunft,
sich auch selbst zu einem Payment Prozessor hin entwickeln, dass sie sagen, ja, zahl das doch mit iTunes.
Ja. Ja.
Oder wie auch immer Sie das dann nennen, ja, also zahl das mit deiner Apple ID. Ja, ja, I-Pay,
Und dann müssen wir alle zahlen,
So, ne? Und natürlich ist es wieder einfach und funktioniert und trallala und wird sich durchsetzen, gar keine Frage. Ne, nur was ist eben mit
äh mit anderen Systemen, die andere Transaktionsmodelle verfolgen und äh eine Liberalisierung auch dieser ganzen Zahlungswege
theoretisch ermöglichen bis hin
natürlich im Falle von Flater, was es eben auch mit Alternativen, Finanzierungsmodellen, die einfach über das normale ich bezahle für einen Kauf hinausgehen,
ist wirklich eine Frage, für die ich keine Antwort habe.
Zum Glück haben wir weise Personen, die über solche Sachen Gedanken machen.
Die wir aber nicht sind.
Nee, genau, auf die wir zurückgreifen. Ähm ich denke, damit haben wir heute mal eine etwas längere Episode wieder gemacht.
Es war ein bisschen heftig. Jetzt hast du nur so Themen rausgesucht, die alle so zu so einem epischen äh äh Miandern äh eingeladen haben. Nein, nein, Vorwurf wäre ja.
Vorwürfe, okay? Am Ende macht er mich hier fertig. Wenn wenn wir gleich fertig sind, dann kriege ich Anschiss vom Chef, ja?
Ich bin noch hier.
Nee, los, wir können hier nicht so. Ich habe dir gesagt, dreiviertel Stunde. Ähm ich wollte noch kurz einen Podcast planken,
haben wir sehr selten ähm aber Netzkinder, Netzkinder AT,
von Thomas Lohninger, der ja auch schon bei uns zu Besuch war, das war die Folge, in der wir uns viel mit Österreich auseinandergesetzt haben und der macht den Podcast Netzkinder zusammen mit, Moment, den Namen muss ich jetzt kurz noch heraussuchen
und die haben auf jeden Fall in der aktuellen Folge einen äh eine Person, die von.
Von dem Vorwurf oder,
Ziel des Vorwurfs war, äh sich enormes angeschlossen zu haben und dort irgendwie eine Führungsposition oder sowas äh zu haben. Und äh da gibt's ein längeres Gespräch, auch gute zwei Stunden von Thomas mit,
Michael Renner, ja und wer wohl auch bei diesem Podcast noch dabei ist, ist,
also der macht auch Netzkinder, aber dieser dieser dieses Gespräch ist erstmal nur Thomas und Michael Renner, kann man auf jeden Fall ähm empfehlen, die Polizei und das Internet heißt die Folge und gibt ähm
Tipps für den souveränen Umgang mit unseren Freunden und Helfern,
Folge eins sei einfach mal hier empfohlen und der Podcast generell auch insbesondere für die österreichischen Hörer, die uns ja auch damals so freundlich gedankt haben, dass wir uns der,
Thematik in Österreich angenommen haben und das macht Thomas da sehr gut.
Genau, jetzt schleimen wir uns noch weiter ein, indem wir jetzt auch noch die Podcasts zu empfehlen.
Und er hält sich, glaube ich, sehr äh gut an die äh Definition, wenn ich mir das so anschaue.
Ja, das ähm habe ich mir auch gerade hier.
Er war ja auch beim Meeting, also hat er da auch sein Teil von mitgenommen. Also, Empfehlung eines Podcasts.
Gut. Und damit war's das hier.
Damit empfehlen wir uns.
Damit empfehlen wir uns ähm und äh ja, eine weitere überlange Folge, aber das muss auch manchmal sein.
Ich quatsche da ganz gerne mit dir. Bitte sei jetzt nicht so böse.
Nee, ich find's auch grad immer immer total knorke.
Bitte schlag mich gleich nicht.
Gut, nächste Woche geht's weiter. Bis bald. Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao.
Bis dahin, ciao, ciao.